une mobilisation qui vous l'avez vu ne
faiblit pas une gestion de la crise
sanitaire contestées notamment dans le
milieu scolaire pour en parler on
retrouve notre éditorialiste et
sociologue michel fize bonjour bonjour
michel et merci d'être avec nous alors
les manifestations aujourd'hui vont dans
la continuité de celle qu'on a observée
cette semaine est ce qu'on peut dire que
le mouvement de contestation grossistes
la france va mal et les français sont en
colère et de plus en plus en colère et
on a l'impression que le mouvement se
solidifie se cristallisent au fil au fil
des semaines tant le mécontentement et
les rancoeurs se sont accumulés au fil
des mois et des mois avec pour point de
départ évidemment le mouvement des gilet
jaune en novembre 2018 donc aujourd'hui
on est à un tournant et aussi peut-être
un tournant dans la balance entre
sécurité et liberté depuis des mois la
balance a semblé plutôt penché du côté
de la sécurité sanitaire aujourd'hui
elle pencherait plutôt avec l'aide
d'ailleurs des tribunaux du côté des
libertés un peu l'exemple aussi de ce
qu'on voit dans d'autres pays où on
dessert les étreintes sur les citoyens
est ce que on peut parler d'une mauvaise
gestion de la crise sanitaire par
l'éducation nationale
j'ai l'impression que c'est pire que ça
on eu l'impression que dans les premiers
temps l'école n'était pas concernée par
la crise qu'elle était une sorte de
sanctuaire hors du temps hors sol avec
avec un ministre qui semblait ne pas
comprendre ce qui se passait autour
autour de lui avec ce discours les
enfants ne sont pas contaminés ils ne
sont pas contaminants donc faisons comme
si rien ne se passait alors on a observé
au fil du au fil des semaines
effectivement des décisions qui étaient
soit dans la précipitation dont trop
rapide soit au contraire un manque de
réactivité avec pour conséquence un
empilement des protocoles des dizaines
de protocoles l'un chassant l'autre et
sans aucune sans aucune concertation sa
vessie
utiliser une image dirais que
l'éducation nationale ressemble à une
forteresse dirigée par un seigneur le
ministre qui régente tout dirige tout
sans aucune concertation et notamment
sans aucune concertation avec les
parents d'enseignants et les parents
d'élèves qui pourtant font partie à part
entière de la communauté éducative
quelle est la part de responsabilité
du ministre jean michel blanquer a donc
là je crois que vous observez je crois
que le ministre incarne une école d'un
autre temps une école hiérarchique
verticale en plus avec peut-être un
caractère qui ne favorise pas le
dialogue c'est vrai que monsieur blanc
caire passe pour un homme austère autun
arrogant sûr de lui et dominateur
pensant avoir raison donc contre contre
tous les autres je crois que l'école
comme toutes les institutions ne peuvent
plus fonctionner cette manière il faut
dialoguer on voit bien que les
enseignants les parents d'élèves
regrette de ne jamais être associés aux
décisions qu'ils apprennent par votre
presse est ce que vous pensez qu'il peut
y avoir un risque d'explosion sociale en
cas de nouvelle vague vous savez les
tensions montent sur un fond de crise
économique
qui s'accroît on parle d'un pouvoir
d'achat qui est quand même bien écornée
1 on annonce des hausses de prix
notamment de produits alimentaires déjà
forte qui risque de l'être davantage un
qu'en sera-t-il des produits de
l'énergie tant qu' il ya quand même tous
les ingrédients pour qu'ils aient cette
cristallisation qui se solidifie encore
un peu plus voilà maintenant personne
n'est devin et on ne sait pas de quoi
demain sera fait merci beaucoup à michel
fils pour toutes ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes sociologue et
éditorialiste precious